Sinnlose Tränen, ich hab mich gefreut, Liederweise stapeln sich die Messflaschen in der Küche, kein Fun für die Liebe, kein Bong of Love, Podcast, UFOs, alles was ich hab, sinnlose Tränen, ich hab mich für dich gefreut, Liederweise, doch später stellt sich raus, ich krieg kein Pfand zurück, kein Pfand für die Liebe und es sind sinnlose Tr ihr damit seid. Nein, wir laden nicht zweimal dieselbe Folge hoch, sondern Daniel drei hat mal wieder delivered. Er ist nun mal... Daniel drei wurde quasi zu Daniel vier, indem er das nächste Intro eingereicht hat. Nein, er hat aus unserem tollen kleinen, naja, Textfesten letzte Woche hat er ein neues Intro komponiert. Man kann sich auf Daniel drei verlassen. Für mich tatsächlich daher aufgestiegen auf Platz Nummer zwei. Der drei Daniels. Nee, er ist immer noch Daniel 3, aber er ist auf Platz zwei. Und von daher vielen, vielen Dank. Es hat mich sehr berührt. Ich glaube, wir haben hier eine romantische Goldmine gefunden. Ja, da sieht man mal. Andere Künstler brauchen irgendwie 15 Jahre fürs neue Album, Dendemann oder sowas. Und Daniel 3 ist einfach, muss man sagen, einer von denen, die von der Muse geküsst, deliveren können und auch mal innerhalb von einer Woche Hits schreiben können. Ich glaube, das kann ein ganzes Album werden. Ich glaube, so Supermarkt-spezifische Liebeslieder, glaube ich, können... Anerkastisch steht dann so Daniel Drei mit so verträumten Gesicht, so einer Gitarre in der Hand. Er sitzt so auf dem Laufband mit seiner Gitarre und fährt so vorbei und dann kommen so gebrochene Herzen vorbei.
Sinnlose Tränen. Und jetzt Daniel Drei mit seinem Top-Hit, verliebt in die Kassiererin. Wenn ich dich sehe, macht mein Herz piep. Zwischen uns passt kein Dekunden-Differenzierungsmodul. Oh, das habe ich noch nicht vergessen. Das habe ich noch nicht vergessen. und hat mit einem gekonnten Wurf, weil ich sah schon, meine Waren waren schon quasi an dem Pieper angekommen. Und dann habe ich noch so ein Differenzierungsmodul genommen und hingeworfen, was hat noch genau dazwischen gepasst. Und dann war gross Gelächter an der Kasse. Was ist denn hier los? Weil man erschreckt sich ja auch vor ruckartigen Bewegungen, erschreckt man sich häufig in der Öffentlichkeit. Habe ich noch geschafft. Nicht schlecht. Zwischen uns passt kein Kundendifferenzierungsmodul. Und natürlich auch mit dem Top-Hit Gebrochenes Herz an Kasse 3. Gebrochenes Herz an Kasse 3, die Verliebe, Verkassierer. Da müsste mal jemand zu der Tiefkühlerabteilung kommen. Da ist ein Glück geschehen. Du bist so heiß, selbst die Tiefkühlerabteilung macht dich nicht weniger heiß. Ja. Okay, wenig gut. Nee, ist ein Brainstorming. Ich weiß nicht, warum du so kritisch bist. Heisse Liebe in der Tiefkühlerabteilung. In der Tiefkühlerabteilung, ja. Heisse Liebe zwischen gefrorenen Cordon-Bloes und Kratzeis. Heisse Liebe in der Tiefkühabteilung. Heisse Liebe zwischen gefrorenen Cordon Bleus und Kratzeis. Heisse Liebe in der Tiefkühlabteilung. Ja, dann natürlich, können Sie mir helfen, mein Herz zu holen von dem Regal ganz oben? Seit meiner letzten Liebe hängt mein Herz ganz viel zu hoch.
In Gang drei.
Dann vielleicht an der Frischetheke fand ich die. Darfst noch etwas mehr sein? Darfst noch etwas mehr sein? Das ist so die Samba-Variante. Darfst noch etwas mehr sein? Nein, ich habe genug. Deine Liebe reicht für zwei. Das ist nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, wir kriegen ein komplettes Album mit. 500 Gramm deiner Liebe hätte ich gerne. So, stimmt schon. Ne, hallo auch einfach von mir zu dieser neuen fantastischen Woche. Eine Woche, wie wir es lange nicht mehr hatten. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze. Ja, die Woche bricht gut an. Es ist weiterhin alle sieben Wochentage da, stehen zur Verfügung. Alle stehen in Rei und Glied und wie so gutes Hotelpersonal, was einem so zunickt. Am Anfang der Woche stehen sie da alle schon und nicken einem zu, man freut sich auf die kommende Zeit. Ja, finde ich gut. Alle stehen parat. Was ist dein Lieblingswochentag? Wo hast du? Oh, natürlich der Freitag. Ja? Ja. Samstag empfinde ich schon als stressig, weil Wochenendstress, den Sonntag empfinde ich als langweilig, weil man nicht rausgehen kann und Dinge kaufen kann. Ich liebe Dinge zu kaufen. Freitag ist der beste Tag, weil du hast die Vorfreude aufs Wochenende, du kannst den Abend schön verbringen mit deinen Liebsten, kannst du dann abends ein bisschen die Puppen aufbleiben, weil du ja nächsten Tag nicht einfach ausschlafen kannst. Von daher ist der Vater auf jeden Fall in meinen Top zwei Wochentagen, der Vater an der Samstag, ja. Ja, ist natürlich leicht, ich finde Samstag eher natürlich Samstag. Kannst lange ausschlafen, kannst lange aufbleiben, perfekt, wunderbar. Besten Filme laufen immer Samstag, 20.15 Uhr, war natürlich lange Zeit der… Bist du denn immer noch ein Filmtyp, 20.15 Uhr, Filmtyp, nein. Nee, nicht 20.15 Uhr, aber ich habe mich jetzt, ich habe mich jetzt entschlossen, ich will wieder mehr Filme laufen immer Samstag, 20.15 Uhr, war natürlich lange Zeit der ... Bist du denn immer noch ein Filmtyp, 20.15 Uhr-Filmetyp? Nein.
Nee, nicht 20.15 Uhr, aber ich habe mich jetzt, ich habe mich dazu entschlossen, ich will wieder mehr Filme sehen und schaue jetzt jeden, jeden Abend will ich einen Film gucken und habe schon einiges weggeguckt jetzt in letzter Zeit, The Lighthouse habe ich gesehen, Under the Silver Lake, Dunkirk habe ich gesehen, also ich arbeite mich so ein bisschen durch die ganzen Filme durch, die ich verpasst habe, alle schon ausgeliehen auf iTunes, oft Ladeschwierigkeiten tatsächlich, oft Fehler im Film tatsächlich, da hält das Bild an. Jedes einzelne Mal denke ich, interessante artistische Entscheidung, jetzt den Ton weiterlaufen zu lassen, aber das Bild friert ein, jedes Mal und dann geht es weiter und dann flimmert das Bild so nach, holt alles schnell nach und dann nicht mehr.
Okay, dann schaust du Star Wars Episode 8, wo es ziemlich ganz kurz mal ruhig ist und da denkst du dann sofort, ist kaputt, machst den Film aus.
Genau, Helligkeit ganz so. Und siehst dann später weiter nach, dass es eine Stelle war, die so geplant war, artistisch. So kann ich nicht mehr Filme gucken. Das ist mir jetzt aufgefallen, ich schlaf ein. Nach Minute zwei schlaf ich ein. Ich kann keine Filme mehr gucken. Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Ich kann nichts mehr gucken. Sobald ich auf dem Sofa liege, schlafe ich sofort ein. Ich habe keine Ahnung genau, woran das liegt. Und sicherlich gab es auch schon mal solche Zeiten. Und jetzt ist gerade wieder so eine Phase. Ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht musst du spannendere Filme schauen, vielleicht brauchst du irgendwie so Horrorfilme oder Schlaflos in Seattle oder irgendwas, was dich so richtig kitzelt, wo du aus dem Lachen nicht mehr rauskommst.
Wie ich Grossteile meines Lebens lase, lag ich mit weit aufgerissenen Augen, spannend auf dem Sofa und habe mir Filme geguckt und Fernsehfragen geguckt und fand das ganz toll. Und in Erwartung, was passiert in der nächsten Szene, mittlerweile Minute zwei. Wohin liegt das denn? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin, ich dachte eigentlich immer, ich schlafe nie bei Filmen ein, wurde dann aber darauf hingewiesen, dass ich einmal im Kino eingeschlafen bin, ohne dass ich es gemerkt habe. Das heißt, du stellst dein ganzes Leben mittlerweile auch in Frage. Ich stelle alles in Frage, wo ich teilweise schaue ich einen Film an und denke mir, irgendwie ergibt die Handlung keinen Sinn, wie sind denn jetzt auf diese Insel gekommen? Und dann denke ich mir, habe ich geschlafen oder? Ich kann mir keine Meinung mehr zu Filmen leisten, weil der
Gegenüber immer in meiner Hauptfragen. Deine ganzen Filmfights-Auftritte müssen revidiert werden. Das sind lächerlich, so der Film ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, am Anfang ist er ein Kind, plötzlich sitzt er im Gefängnis, ich meine, was hat er angestellt als Kind und dann so, war da ewig lange Geschichte, wie er zum Kriminellen wurde. Drei Stunden geschlafen.
Ich weiss doch nicht, was der Situation im Film findet, der ist vier Minuten lang irgendwie.
Ich weiss nicht, kommen die Anfangs-Credits und dann geht schon wieder die Endmusik los. Irgendwie hat es mich nicht gepackt. Aber interessant, ich bin bei Saving Mr. Banks eingeschlafen, Tom Hanks spielt Walt Disney und anscheinend irgendwo bin ich ausgestiegen, ohne es zu merken. Und mein Sitznachbar hat mich wach gerempelt, auch das habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Ich habe einfach den Film normal geguckt. Du skippst also auch den unangenehmen Parts ins Einschlafen. Ich skipp alles. Ich schaue den Film und komme aus dem Kino und sage, ja, war okay. Und meine Begleitung sagt, hast du nicht gemerkt, dass du eingeschlafen bist? Echt? Ja. Das ist wirklich wahnsinnig lustig. Hast du schon mal während des Podcasts hier geschlafen? Ich kann es nicht garantieren, dass ich nicht eingeschlafen bin. Du kannst es nicht ausschliessen mehr. Ich kann es wirklich nicht ausschliessen. Schlafen ist generell eine seltsame Idee. Super seltsam. Und ich habe tatsächlich, ich will noch ein paar Sachen freischalten im Schlaf. Man hört ja so luzides Träumen und so, will das mal ausprobieren und so. Was aber, was ich auch mal gerne erleben würde, und das hat ein Freund von mir erlebt, der kam eines Morgens in die Schule und war völlig außer sich, völlig durch den Wind und war so, was passiert irgendwie, überfahren auf dem Weg zur Schule oder so und er so, hey, jetzt ist das ganz, ganz, was passiert. Ich lag gestern im Bett, wollte einschlafen und dann mache ich kurz die Augen zu und wieder auf und es war der nächste Tag. Also so wirklich so, als der gesamte Schlaf war so in einem Augenblinzeln weg. Wie als hätte man bei Die Sims unten auf den Schneller-Button gedrückt. Genau. Und also er hätte man eingefroren, vorgespult und wieder aufgetaut. Das ist wirklich so, also normalerweise ist der Schlaf ja merkwürdig, weil man hat keinen klaren Auspunkt, man kann nicht sagen, nach dem Gedanken bin ich eingeschlafen gestern und hat keinen klaren Anfangspunkt. Bei dem war das so wirklich so zack, kurzer Moment und dann war nächsterster Tag. Von dunkel zu hell sofort. Es ginge plötzlich das Licht an und der nächste Tag ist da. Und das würde ich auch noch mal gerne erleben. Also falls ihr da Mittel und Wege kennt. Ehrlich gesagt, ich mag das dieses Zwischenweltliche, den Aspekt am Schlafen, dieses man döst weg. Es ist eine Form von Side-Reise. Die Gedanken, die man da hat und so, wenn man so kurz vor dem Wegdösen ist, dann teilweise, wenn man in unruhigen Nächten, was man einen sehr einen Quatsch in seinem Kopf, so fiebertraumartig zusammenspinnt, auch Wahnsinn, will ich auch nicht missen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber angenommen, irgendwann kommt mal so eine Alienrasse auf die Erde und die haben noch nicht von dem Prinzip Schlaf gehört, was ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann, weil wie dusselig ist das, dass wir, also manche Tiere, die meistens in ihrem Leben, in dieser Standby-Position sind. Ja, schläft so ein Wurm, so ein Regenwurm? Ich glaube, manche Tiere schlafen auf jeden Fall länger, als dass sie wach sind. Wie so eine Katze, so ein Wurm, dass der so wie so eine Spirale sich einhängt. Nee, der legt sich einfach nur hin auf die Seite. Der räumt so um 90 Grad und schläft. Aber Wurm ist ein Seitenschläfer, in der Nacht dreht er sich nochmal um auf die andere Seite. Dreht sich nochmal um, ja. The worm has turned, sagt man ja. The worm has turned. The worm is er. The worst worm. Worst worm. Übrigens, Best Bird hat sich gemeldet. Für alle, die es nicht wissen, wir wollten die Domain bestbird.com bekommen, ich habe 50 Dollar geboten, kostet 19.000.
Und auf mein Angebot ...
Also deutlich teurer als Worst Bird.
Wesentlich teurer als Worst Bird.
Verstehe ich nicht, weil Worst Bird, nee, finde ich auch überraschend.
Und wir haben gesagt, nee, 19.000 geht nicht, ich habe 50 Dollar.
Jetzt bar auf die Kralle. Und da hat er sehr höflich gesagt, das wird nichts.
Jetzt meldet er sich aber nochmal und sagt, wie schaut es aus, können wir nicht irgendwo zusammenkommen? Ich denke mir so, du kennst meine finanzielle Situation. Können wir uns nicht in der Mitte treffen? Und ich habe ihm nicht geantwortet, weil ich wollte Macht demonstrieren. Ja, oder du demonstrierst, du hast jetzt auch kein Geld mehr für deine Internetleitung. 70-30, man weiß es nicht genau. Und dann hat er nochmal geschrieben und dann hat er sogar geschrieben, I don't want to be a pest, but ... I don't want to be a pest? Ja, und dann, ich will nicht nerven, aber weißt du, der Typ ... Ich will nicht die Pest sein, was ein toller Ausdruck ist. Na, Pest heißt ja auch sowas wie Ungeziefer, ne, also das ist immer schwer so bei englischen Sachen, man weiß nicht genau, wie die Konnotation ist. Es ist so, ich will jetzt kein Ungeziefer sein, aber wollen wir nochmal ... Nervensäge wahrscheinlich. Ich will keine Nervensäge sein, ja. Wird wahrscheinlich auch für einen Engländer merkwürdig sein. I don't want to be a nerving saw. Und er schreibt zweimal einer Person, von der er weiss, dass sie 18.950 Dollar zu wenig hat, um die Domain zu kaufen. Aber hast du wieder gesagt, du hast nur 50 Dollar? Noch habe ich nicht geantwortet. Nee, aber deine erste Nachricht war deine erste Nachricht, ich biete 50 Dollar oder ich habe nur 50 Dollar? Erst biete, dann habe. Geschrieben, ich biete 50 Dollar und er hat gesagt, nee, 19 Dollar. Okay, ich habe nur 50 Dollar. Und so ist es leider stehen geblieben. Okay, bin sehr gespannt. Ich lasse ihn weiter zappeln, bis er irgendwann sagt, hey, what about those 50 bucks, can we talk about it? Weil im Endeffekt, wir alle wissen, Best Bird, so wichtig ist es nicht. Ist nicht so wichtig. Ja, finde ich gut. Best Bird. Genau, wir immer schlafen auf der Seite, das ist ein allgemeines Phänomen. Viele Tiere schlafen aber auch länger, als sie wirklich beim Bewusstsein sind, was ich immer faszinierend finde. Wenn jetzt eine Alienrasse kommt, die irgendwann, für die sind wir doch ein gefundenes Fressen. Die kommen ja einfach, wenn die dunkel ist. Ja, oder es ist halt mega langweilig für die, weil die unterhalten sich halt und dann so, wir gehen ins Bett und die so, wie ins Bett. Wir legen uns jetzt acht Stunden lang hin und machen nichts. Ja, so ungefähr zwei Drittel des Lebens schlafen wir. Okay, können wir dann hierbleiben für die Zeit? Ja, klar, dann nehme ich einen Kaffee. Ja, dann setze ich mich hier hin und dann sehen wir uns in acht Stunden. Und dann steht man ja auch morgens auf, die Eltern sitzen dann noch da, warten auf einen. Schweigend. Schweigend, sind so, klopfen so auf den Tisch ab und zu. Ja, und dann kommt man ja auch erst mal an, dann ist man ja auch erst mal, man kommt ja erst in den Tag, ist ja nicht so, dass die Menschen dann sofort wach sind, wenn sie aufstehen, nein, ist ja erst mal zwei Stunden lang, oh, ich mach mir erst mal einen Kaffee. So, können wir weiter über das intergalaktische Abkommen verhandeln, weil, wie gesagt, die Orgonen, die drohen damit die komplette Universität zu versklaven.
Oh, Sonnenkaffee. Oder erst mal Frühstücken.
Ich nehme einen Koffinierten bitte, wenn es geht.
Wollen wir Frühstücken gehen oder wollen wir irgendwie was bestellen oder so? Komm, aber uns ein Rüreei. Bestellen? Eier? Kennen Sie Eier? Machen wir irgendwie, ich kann Spiegler machen, Omelette oder so. Ja, komm. Aber vor allem, ich kann oft nicht einschlafen, weil ich mir zu viel Druck mache, dass ich einschlafen muss. So im Sinne von, wenn du jetzt nicht einschlafen bist, bist du morgen müde. Wenn du jetzt nicht einschlafen bist, bist du morgen müde und dann kann ich einschlafen. Glaub ich, ist gängig. Aber für mich wäre es der Horror, irgendwie so ein Bär zu sein, der Winterschlaf macht. Stell dir mal vor, du legst dich hin, Winter schlafst, schlaf ich vier Monate und du kannst nicht einschlafen. Du denkst dir, ja wie, das geht nicht, ich habe nicht genug gegessen. Wenn ich jetzt nicht einschläfe, verhungere ich einfach. Oder wache zu früh auf und dann ist alles kalt. Und dann, ich habe meine Mütze nicht da. Aber ratzen die durch? Also, müssen die nicht mal raus? Wird da durchgeratzt? Stehen die nicht mal so ganz verschlafen? Oh, in so einem Kühlschrank so. Oh, noch ein bisschen Tiramisu von gestern. Ja, von September. Und dann gehen sie wieder zurück ins Bettchen. Jetzt ein bisschen Honig, noch so ein kleiner Honigtopf. Und schlafen sie ein, dann klebt so die Brote am Mund. Ja, aber schlafen die durch oder haben die auch zwischendurch so Phasen? Also haben die auch Tiefschlafphasen und Rem-Phasen? Du, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man mal einen Bär in so ein Schlaflabor geholt hat und gesagt hat, Freunde, wir geben uns mal 140.000 Euro aus, um einen Bären einfach mal an so ein EKG anzuschliessen für eine Winterschlafsitzung und der Bär ist nervös und fuck, ich kann das nicht, ist noch vor der Tür, raucht eine und sagt, komm, passt schon, so, mach einfach wie immer, geht nicht, ist schwierig, geht nicht unter Laborbedingungen. Gibt es manche Dinge, die man nicht untersuchen kann, weil die unter Laborbedingungen nicht funktionieren? Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. Wie diese kleinsten Teilchen, die so klein sind, dass der Messvorgang die verändert. Ja, die sind halt so ein bisschen wie bei Supermache, die Geister, die bewegen sich nur, wenn man nicht hinguckt. Und dann immer so, die hat sich bewegt, ja okay, dann mach jetzt die Mess-, die Kamera an. Jetzt bewegen wir uns nicht. Okay, wir drehen uns jetzt weg auf drei, eins, zwei, ah, ah, ah, kurz bewegen. Vielleicht. Und das Higgs-Boson so, ach komm, Leute, come on, ich dachte, ihr guckt nicht. Ich kann nicht, wenn ihr guckt. Das Higgs-Boson kann nicht, wenn wir gucken, so heißt meine wissenschaftliche Abhandlung, mein Sachbuch über das Higgs-Boson, ich kann nicht, wenn ihr guckt. Das Higgs-Person kann nicht, wenn wir gucken. So heißt meine wissenschaftliche Abhandlung, mein Sachbuch über das Higgs-Person.
Ich kann nicht, wenn ihr guckt.
Ja, gute Frage, weiß ich nicht genau.
Aber bestimmt, also ich glaube, niemand ist mit allem, der forschen kann.
Ich glaube, die meisten Sachen verändern sich, weil man irgendwie ein Mikrofon oder eine Kamera drauf hält.
Ich glaube, die Menschen ja auch.
Wenn man denkt, dass es ein richtiges Abbild des Menschen ist, was im Fernsehen zu sehen ist oder in Filmen, ist ja albern.
Ich bin ja sofort anders, wenn die Kamera auf mich gerichtet ist. Du bist ja Schauspieler vor allem oder Moderator. Du schimpfst dich ja so. Merkst du dann noch aktiv, dass du anders bist, sobald eine Kamera auf dich gerichtet ist? Das ist ja die Idee, dass man anders ist. Es wäre ja blöd, wenn ich genauso wäre wie nicht, aber es gibt natürlich schon diesen Effekt, dass plötzlich alles künstlich wird. Aber gerade in Zeiten, das ist schon klar, aber ja gerade in den neuen, postmodernen Kamera auf Leute halten, es ist ja schon so, dass es um Authentizität geht viel. Also ich meine, so ein Sender wie Rocket Beans TV lebt ja von authentischen Charakteren, YouTube lebt von authentischen Charakteren, das ist immer das Schlagwort des Internets neuerdings, so Leute wollen halt authentische Leute vor der Kamera haben. Das stimmt schon, aber es sind ja zwei verschiedene Sachen, also jetzt allein, wenn du jetzt eine Szene zehnmal spielst und zehn Takes hast, das ist ja was ganz anderes, als wenn du einfach vierzehn Minuten lang Moin Moin durchmoderierst, aber wenn du dieses bei einem Filmdreh des zehn Takes hast, dann fällt dir schon plötzlich auf, alles was ich mache, ist künstlich. Das Schlimm ist so, ja wir drehen heute nur wie du die Treppe hochgehst. Und du denkst, ja geil, Blocker Drehtag, merkst aber in Take drei, wie gehen die Füsse, wo sind die Hände, was machen Hände, what do hands do? Ja und dann irgendwie machst du ein Take und dann kommt der Regisseur und meint, ja ja war ganz gut, wir müssen es noch eine machen wegen Licht, aber guck mal, dass du ein bisschen natürlicher läufst.
Du, ich habe gerade nicht versucht,
möglichst unnatürlich zu laufen.
Das hat man ja häufig. Danke für das Feedback.
Ich hatte auch mal so einen Monat, wie jetzt diesen Monat,
den ich habe, wo ich einsteige, wo ich bei Filmen,
hatte ich auch mal so einen Monat, wo ich vergessen habe zu gehen.
Oder halt so einen Monat, wo man mal zu sehr
auf die Atmung achtet und dann vergisst zu atmen.
Das hatte ich auch schon mal.
Und das hat man manchmal, wenn man sich die Dinge bewusst macht. Da hat mir irgendwer gesagt, du gehst komisch und dann achtet man auf seinen Gang und dann geht man erst richtig komisch.
Weil, also man hat das ja so grob im Kopf, wie Leute gehen. Und dann habe ich immer gedacht, man hat ja so eine leichte Auf-Ab-Bewegung auch drin. Also so eine Hüfte-Links-Rechs-Bewegung und eine leichte Kopf-Auf-Ab-Bewegung und so eine Fuss-Hoch-Bewegung. Wie genau das dann aussieht, wenn man selber geht, weiss man ja dann nicht. Ja, stimmt. Eigentlich hat man immer so im Kopf nur vorne, vorne, vorne, als würde man so den Control-Stick nach vorne drücken die ganze Zeit. Aber man hat nicht links, rechts, links, sondern einfach nur, ich will nach vorne. Ich strebe gerne vorne. Aber wenn du vorne hast und keine Auf- und Ab- und Rechts-Links-Bewegungen mit dem Kopf alleine schon, dann gehen deine Beine so mega seltsam schwebend. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber manchmal kommt mir jemand entgegen, wo ich mir denke, ist es der erste Tag auf der Erde, wo die Arme so ganz weit schwingen und ich denke so, ist das, bist du ein Alien, wenn, können wir darüber reden?
Du hast ja gerade den Touring-Test bei dir nicht bestanden.
Ach so, ja.
Weil der gebaute Roboter offensichtlich falsch geht.
Er lernt gerade noch das Gehen.
In die Büsche geworfen habe, weil ich dachte, das ist ein Roboter.
Ja.
Ja, das ist schon schwierig.
Das ist schwierig.
Aber ich glaube, das Ideal ist ja schon so, es gibt ja so aus alten Knigge Sachen so, dass man dann so laufen muss mit einem Buch auf dem Kopf. Ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass es nicht runterfällt, sondern dass man ganz still ist der Kopf die ganze Zeit. Aber war halt, weiß ich auch nicht, war halt auch eine andere Zeit irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Lief man damals anders? Also lief der Durchschnittsmensch so in Mozarts Zeiten anders durch Wien? Kann schon sein, es gibt ja so alte Schwarz-Weiss-Aufnahmen, wo die alle so ganz schnell laufen. Ja, auch immer und schnell reden und hochreden. Zack, zack, zack, und so wumm, wumm, wumm, weg. Einfach schon die ganze Zeit weg. Berlin, Berlin, der Mensch hat keine Zeit, Berlin. Und dann laufen die so schnell, und die reden auch so, professionelle Sprecher hatten diese schrille Stimme, oder war das Tonverzöger? Kann aber auch daran liegen, dass das Mikrofon nur eine gewisse Bandbreite aufnimmt und den Rest nicht und da ist ein knarriger Ton. Berlin Alexanderplatz! Alexanderplatz! Die haben weder einen polnischen Akzent gehabt, noch haben die hochgesprochen, noch sind die aktiv schneller gelaufen, das waren einfach technische Limitationen. Es kam alles durch die Technik. Aber eigentlich war das wie heute. Die Welt hat ja auch Farbe gehabt. Habe ich als Kind immer nicht gedacht, weil du kennst die Welt ja nur durch die Schwarz-Weiss-Aufnahmen. Aber es ist ja wirklich was dran, dass wir wirklich denken, dass die Vergangenheit nicht bunt ist. Weil zum Beispiel so römische Statuen, die waren ja bemalt. Also die waren ja nicht weiß, sondern die waren angemalt. Die waren ja bunt. Im Film Gladiator ja nicht. Eben. und wir denken uns, wenn wir uns das antike Rom vorstellen, stellen wir uns auch so alle Gebäude als weiss vor, aber die waren halt vielleicht knallgelb oder grün.
Ja, so geil bunt.
Violetten Punkten.
Nee, aber wahnsinnig bunt wahrscheinlich.
Ja, wahnsinnig bunt, aber das ist halt über die Jahrtausende natürlich halt weg, aber es ist ja echt so, dass wir uns die Vergangenheit immer nur einfarbig, auch so eine Ritterburg, wenn wir an eine Ritterburg denken, denken wir an Grau. Wer sagt denn, dass die nicht knallgrün bemalt war? Ist das so? Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Also ich glaube, was man oft vergisst, ist, dass die Dächer hatten, also zumindest auf den Zinnen, so auf der Mauer, dass da noch ein Holzdach natürlich drüber war, dass die nicht einfach so die ganze Zeit in den Regen schien. Hat ja auch geregnet manchmal. Ja, die auch gerechnet manchmal. Hatten die häufig einen Sonnenbrand? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, wenn du dann ganz, ich glaube, die waren mehr in der Freien. Warum sind wir so empfindlich, was Sonne angeht? Weil wir den ganzen Tag im Haus sind. Warum verbrennen wir so vor, wenn wir rausgehen, als wäre es nicht unser Heimatplanet? Naja, weil wir den ganzen Tag drin sitzen, weil wir im Auto sitzen, weil wir im Bus sitzen, weil wir uns keine Cabrios leisten können. Reiche Menschen haben weniger Sonnenbrand, weil sie im Cabrio sitzen. Geniale Idee. Oder weil es nicht unser Heimatplanet ist. Und au, du meinst, wir wurden durch ein Experiment hier auf dieser Erde gepflanzt, um zu sehen, wie wir uns verhalten würden. Eigentlich stammen Menschen von wo ganz anders her und wir sind sozusagen so eine große Truman-Show, wo überwacht wird und dann werden so verschiedene Katastrophen auf uns geworfen. Und dann wird geguckt wie wir darauf reagieren, als großes Experiment und genau wie du vorhin gesagt hast, wir dürfen nicht wissen, dass es ein Experiment wäre, sonst würde es das Experiment vertuschen. Das willst du damit sagen? Das will ich damit sagen. Genau, das kann auch sein. Das kann auch sein. Stimmt schon. Wie ein Beinhalter durch die Galaxis, immer noch einer meiner liebsten Bücher. Kann ich nur empfehlen. Ganz toll gelesen von Christian Ulm. Insider-Tipp. Okay, Empfehlung. Dann empfehle ich auch was. Harry Potter. Ich empfehle euch James Bond. Spannende, spannende Geschichten. Auf was ich nötig gestossen bin, sind so, es ist eine Trilogie, gibt auch andere Filme, Trilogie über, ich weiß nicht, wie er hieß, so ein Bodo oder so. Bodo? Ja, Bodo muss einen Ring ins Feuer werfen. Ah, klingt gut. Wo wir gerade weisen, kann ich auch empfehlen, was ich letztens entdeckt habe, Musik. Also das ist ganz verrückt. Was ist das? Beschreib mal. Es sind so Geräusche, aber in unterschiedlicher Höhe und Länge. Ah, ich habe gehört, die irgendwie auch schön klingen. Ja, es ist unterschiedlich, aber es ist in sich halt irgendwie, und dann ist es halt immer in so einer wiederholenden Muster, und dann wippt man da so mit. Also es ist total verrückt, checkt es mal aus, musik.de, guckt da einfach mal vorbei und lasst ein Like da. Und schaut euch das mal an. Also nur mal jetzt als Idee, einfach nur mal rausgehauen. Guckt mal,
ob es euch gefällt.
Letzte Woche hast du Filme empfohlen.
Ja, und du hast den Schlaf entdeckt.
Man kann ja sagen, jetzt mal ganz kurz politisch. Achtung, wollen wir kurz in die Politikecke? Oh nein, jetzt schweige ich und stoche mit der Gabel in meinem Kuchen. Spult lieber mal vor. Betretenes Vorspulen. Man kann ja über Donald Trump sagen, was man will. Oh mein Gott. Aber Donald Trump wurde interviewt von Ali G in der Ali G Show. Und hat ja immer so Fake-Interviews gemacht mit berühmten Leuten und die dann aufs Eis geführt.
Glatteis, muss man immer Glatteis sagen? Ich finde Glatteis auch eine Tautologie. Extrem. Gut, aufs Raueis geführt. Und unter anderem hat er interviewt Donald Trump. Und die Idee ist halt, dass Adi G die Figur unterschätzt wird, weil er so dumm redet, aber der Schauspieler eigentlich sehr klug ist und deswegen interessante Aussagen aus dem Gegenüber rausbringen kann.
Und dann hat er Donald Trump gefragt, was ist die beliebteste Sache der Welt?
Und das ist ja keine so leichte Frage.
Und er hat den echten Donald Trump gefragt, what's the most popular thing? Und Donald Trump hat gesagt, Musik. Und ich finde, das ist eine nahezu perfekte Antwort. Ich meine, man könnte sowas sagen wie Sex vielleicht, aber ich finde, Musik ist wirklich die perfekte Antwort. Also unter den Top drei Antworten. Und ich habe das letzte nochmal gesehen und dachte mir, weißt du was? Meine Stimme hast du. Den werde ich. Man kann da viele dumme Sachen drauf sagen, aber ich finde, weil Donald Trump ist ja auch ein Geschäftsmann, das heißt, für den ist ja auch sofort die Vermarktung wichtig und mit Musik verdient man wahnsinnig viel Geld, alle Menschen lieben Musik, Musik ist immer
ein Thema, wird immer ein Thema sein, war immer
ein Thema, ist die perfekte Antwort.
Ja.
Oder, was würdest du sagen, was ist die beliebte
Antwort? Nee, ist eine super Antwort, das ist nicht eine super Antwort.
Hätte ich ihm nicht zugetraut. Nee, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Nee, weil der ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht dusselig.
Ja, jetzt kennt man ihn ja besser, damals
wusste ich als Deutscher
nicht unbedingt, wer Donald Trump ist, so halt, ja, das ist halt irgendwie so ein milder Geschäftsraum. Bist du mit diesem Video reingeschlittert in die ganze Donald Trump-Zeit? Nee, ich habe es letztens erst einmal gesehen. Ich habe noch mal ein paar alte Ad-G-Sachen angeguckt. Genau, aber das ist schon älter, das Video. Das kanntest du schon, bevor du was über ihn wusstest. Ja, ja, genau. Das heißt, du bist eigentlich ein bisschen von der anderen Seite gekommen. Ich bin von der anderen Seite gekommen. Vielleicht hilft jemandem wie Donald Trump, weil er Musik so wichtig erachtet. Ja, ich habe relativ schnell meine Fahne geändert, war aber die ersten zwei Wochen noch sehr dabei. Ah, das ist auch die Kappe auf, aber die Magerkappe. Nein, aber es gab schon Phasen in meinem Leben, wo ich mir dachte, gut, dass ich in der Zeit nicht meine Meinung gesagt habe, weil ich die danach geändert habe und sehr glücklich damit bin, dass ich meine Meinung geändert habe. Ja, ja. Oh, deswegen, dass ich noch manchmal Sachen sage, die ich gar nicht mehr so meine. Ihr müsst euch mal dringend, also Meinungen datet man ja nicht ab. Das ist mir so aufgefallen. Eigentlich braucht man eine Liste, eine Excel-Tabelle mit allen Themen, allen Meinungen, die man hat. Unentscheinend, allein das Verbalisieren von Meinungen hilft total, um zu checken, weil natürlich ist unsere Sprache limitiert.
Natürlich ist unsere Sprache nicht gleich unsere Gedanken. Wir haben mehr Gedanken, komplexere Gedanken und unsere Sprache hilft uns nur einigermaßen, das in so eine Form zu gießen. Aber das in eine Form gießen hilft total, um sich selber zu verstehen. Ich glaube, Leute, die Tagebuch führen und deswegen auch, weil die sortierten Kopf so, weil und ich glaube, wenn du was selber lisierst und eine Excel-Tabelle machst, wirklich mit Themen und meiner Meinung dazu. Und bei der Hälfte deiner aktuellen Meinungen sagst du, fuck, die kommt aus meiner Abi-Zeit oder sowas. Das ist eine Bullshit-Meinung. Stimmt, und dann muss man auch aufschreiben, wann man die so geschrieben hat. Und dann immer einmal im Jahr guckt man in dieses Dokument rein. Was man jetzt dazu sagt.
Genau, und dann so, es wäre ja total interessant zu wissen,
was habe ich 2016 gedacht zu
Thema X,
also Themen, die es halt immer gibt, irgendwie keine Ahnung,
Ostkonflikt oder so und dann
natürlich erstmal die ersten Jahre, Frankzeichen,
leer, links zu Wikipedia
und dann, ja. Ich glaube, so Finanzpolitik bin ich
unglaublich konservativ geworden.
Also da habe ich mal, ich habe mal super egal, also da gab auch viele graue Stellen, so Finanzpolitik bin ich unglaublich konservativ geworden. Also da habe ich mal, ich habe mal super, egal, also da gab es auch viele graue Stellen, so Xe, weil ich auch keine Meinung zu hatte. Eben mal mit 17 hat man die erste Meinung zur finanziellen Politik. So, dann war die sehr liberal, liberal, konservativ, erzkonservativ, rechts. Ja, so. Und ich glaube, das ist immer spannend, auch manchmal zu beobachten, was sind so Grafen. Vielleicht zu den eigenen Meinungen. Und das Beste daran ist, dass bei so einer echter Tabelle du niemanden hast, dem du gefallen willst. Und vor allem dann kannst du... Was nicht stimmt, man will sich ja selber gefallen. Dann kannst du, wenn du eine neue Person triffst, der Person auch einfach so eine neue Lebensabschnittgefährtin, Gefährte, kannst du einfach sagen, pass auf, sind meine Meinungen. Das ist aber Pflicht in der Zeit. Das ist Pflicht,
weil es ist ja nervig, wenn du Zeit investierst,
eine neue Person kennenlernst und dann, uh, man
versteht sich hier und da und nach ein paar
Monaten merkt man, ach scheiße, der hat
eine total beschissene Meinung zu dem Thema,
das ist ein Dealbreaker, hätte
ich das mal gleich gewusst, hätte ich die Excel-Tabelle
gehabt von Anfang an und hätte genau gewusst,
wie, du findest
Fluch der Karibik cooler als Herr der Ringe, ciao, wow? Wenn alle Filme aufgelistet sind, die man gesehen hat, das ist eine lange Liste. Naja, ich meine, man müsste wahrscheinlich so einzelne Kernfragen herausarbeiten, die wichtig sind. Israel, ja gut, Finanzpolitik ist schwierig, Finanzpolitik, Musik, Feminismus, Sexismus. Und ich glaube, das reicht, da kann man Menschen komplett abdecken. Und dann kannst du denen zuschicken und sofort wissen, was los ist. Das stimmt wohl. Werbung. Was passiert, wenn wir unseren Blick auf jedes noch so kleine Detail richten, wenn wir neben noch so kleinen Element feilen, bis sich seine ganze Schönheit offenbart, und was passiert dann erst, wenn wir all diese Teile wieder seinem grossen Ganzen zusammensetzen? Der neue Dell XPS 13! Wow! Jaaa!
Endlich! Du weisst ja auch selber, dass der Inhaber Paul Dell hat schon im Jahre 1483 angefangen Laptops zu bauen. Damals hat man ihn ausgelacht, heute glaube ich, lachen die wenigsten, wenn er seinen neuen Dell XPS 13 vorstellt. Das Tolle an dem Laptop ist, dass er nicht nur ein fantastischer Laptop ist, sondern das grosse Problem ist, Das grosse Problem ist, wenn man den Laptop mit ins Bett nimmt, schaut noch um drei Uhr nachts eine tolle Serie und die Augen schmerzen, die stechen. Ja, wegen diesem hässlichen blauen Dreckslicht. Ah, dieses blaue Licht, aber da haben die Füchse von Dell sich was ausgedacht. Genau, nämlich die haben das Easy-Safe-Display eingebaut und das ist schon für eure Augen das erste Panel, das die Lichtenergie an der Quelle intelligent verwaltet. Alle Informationen erhaltet ihr jedenfalls auf dell.de.xps, da findet ihr alle Informationen zum neuen XPS 13, der Laptop aus der Zukunft. Ich habe mal, also ein Kumpel von mir hat etwas sehr Tolles gesagt, nämlich... Sind wir immer noch in der Politik-Ecke eigentlich gerade? Ach so, ja. Ja, okay. Das ist kein Ding, ich muss nur mal gucken. Ich versuche ein bisschen anzuecken. Für die Teilen zu sagen. Ich versuche mit mehr Nebensätzen zu sprechen. Und der besagte Kumpel hat nämlich gesagt, dass wenn er zwei Leute kennt, wie zum Beispiel mich und ich bin mit ihm sehr gut befreundet und er kennt einen anderen Freundeskreis, den er ähnlich gut kennt und ähnlich mag und er weiß, weil er uns beide kennt, beide Lebensgeschichten kennt, dass wir auch sehr gut befreundet sind und ich dann zum ersten Mal sein müssten oder könnten, weil wir uns gut verstehen würden, weil er weiss, woher man jeweils kommt. Und dann trifft man sich auch zum ersten Mal, weil der Freund die neue Stadt besucht von meinem jetzigen Kumpel. So, und dann trifft man sich zum ersten Mal und er sitzt daneben und muss erst mal dieses, ja, wo kommst du her, ja, was hast du studiert, erst mal diesen bürokratischen Scheiss miterleben. Und am liebsten würde er daneben sitzen und sagen, so, jetzt skippen wir das alles. Copy and paste von dem, was ich schon weiß über euch. Und wir sind alle beste Freunde. Eigentlich so, man muss ja sagen, hier, von dem ist das passiert, hier, Mutter gestorben, hier, beste Freundin, hier hier hängt. Wie so eine Einladung, wenn einer schon in der App ist und der andere, und man lädt den so ein und wenn er annimmt, hat er den ganzen Wissensstand schon. Wir sehen den Verlauf komplett. Der ist schon geupdatet, so komplett. Ja, und er gibt beiden so ein Hangout, so ein Pamphlet von dem anderen jeweils. Ja, wie mehr Handouts. Oh mein Gott. Boah, ey, tatsächlich, wenn ich zurückdenke an meine Schulzeit, was vermisse ich am meisten? Handouts. Einfach alles zusammengefasst auf einem Zettel zu haben, genial. Dann aber auch natürlich, wenn man selber einen Referat hat, die Angst, was schreibe ich aufs Handout. Einmal habe ich einfach irgendeine Karte, die im Buch war, abgedruckt und als Handout ausgeteilt, obwohl sie nichts mit dem zu tun hatte, was ich gesagt habe, aber es sah gut aus. Und das hatte einfach was. Ansonsten erinnere ich mich noch an einen Mitschüler, der ein Referat gehalten hat und ein Handout gehabt hatte mit dem Thema des Referats als Überschrift und dann ganz viele leere Zeilen, sodass man selber sich Notizen gemacht hat. Und die Lehrerin hat bewusst relativ, ja, zu Recht gesagt, ja, die Leute haben Blätter Papier, das müsst ihr nicht austeilen, aber danke, dass ihr dran denkt. Smart, und auf dem Blatt war auch noch ein Bild von dem Schüler drauf, der das Referat gehalten hat. Also das Thema, irgendwie Flucht und Leid in den besetzten Gebieten während dem Dritten Reich und dann eben ein Bild von ihm und dann ganz viele leere Zeilen.
Grossartig, beste Handout, das habe ich auch noch lange aufgehoben, weil ich dachte, das ist ein Traum. Ja, das bin ich grossartig. Ja, finde ich, heute bin ich zufällig auf den Button gekommen, der meine Mails nach Datum umsortiert. Boah, und ich habe meine ersten Mails gelesen.
Oh ja.
Und da habe ich eine Mail gefunden, also von dem Account, und dann habe ich eine Mail gefunden an einen Lehrer tatsächlich, in dem ich, hallo Herr, hier finden Sie mein Referat zur NS-Ideologie, mit freundlichen Grüßen, Stefan Thiese, PS, das Handout, habe ich in Anführungszeichen geschrieben, kriegen Sie dann morgen. Und dann habe ich heute noch gelesen, die Antwort war, das ist nicht, hallo Stefan, das soll nicht einfach nur ein dahergelaufenes Handout in Anführungszeichen sein, das soll ein Handout sein, ohne Anführungszeichen. Wenn das das Feedback ist, ich will kein Handout, ich will ein Handout. Mit freundlichen Grüßen, PS, deine Präsentation sieht schön aus. Ja, weil ich war der Einzige, der die nie mit PowerPoint gemacht hat, sondern mit Prezi. Oh ja, Prezi ist gut. Ja, Prezi macht wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Braucht man aber Internet, glaube ich, oder? Nee, ist ja per Flash, Flash-Information. Ach so. Brauchst kein Internet, das ist auch das Beste daran. Du kannst, die Kunden sind immer, und es sieht immer perfekt aus. Sie sind immer ein bisschen besser aus, aus seine kontrahenten oder wie andere sie nennen mitschüler aber feinde feindchen das war das war eine lustige zeit aber ich mache das mal sortiert mal eure mails nach datum um ja was ihr da für einen stuss erst mal seht ihr auch was ihr für lächerliche arschlöcher war damals man war ja ein furchtbares arres Arschloch, das weiß man oft nicht. Ich habe auch noch mal Mails gelesen, da hatte ich einen Job während der Uni und da habe ich mich ein bisschen mit dem Chef angelegt von dieser Firma. Das war der, dem ich auch das Du wieder entzogen habe. Das kann man nicht. Doch, habe ich gemacht. Ja, aber kann es nicht. Doch, geht aber. Wir haben uns kennengelernt, gesiezt und dann irgendwann haben wir uns geduzt und dann habe ich irgendwann gesagt, ich möchte, dass sie mich siezen. Und dann sind wir wieder auf sie zurückgegangen, weil ich den so nicht leiden konnte, diesen Chef.
Und mich hat das so genervt, dass der einerseits so ein Arschloch ist zu seinen Mitarbeitern und andererseits da einen auf Kumpel macht und so. Und ich habe gesagt, nee, wenn du ein Arschloch bist, dann sei auch ein Arschloch, dann sei der böse Zigarettenrauchende Chef und komm mir nicht an, mir du, was hast du am Wochenende gemacht?
Und da gab es einen E-Mail-Austausch mit dem, wo anscheinend irgendein Mitarbeiter einen Fehler gemacht hat und herausfinden wollte, welcher Mitarbeiter den Fehler gemacht hat. Und er hat wirklich eine komplette Hexenjagd angestachelt und hat gesagt, ich will jetzt wissen, wer das gemacht hat, ich weiß, das und das sind die Hinweise, die ich schon rausgefunden habe. Er hat einen Hut getragen, er hat nur eine Hand und hat gerumpelt.
Und Schnurrbart. Das trifft auf sieben Mitarbeiter zu. Und er hat tatsächlich geschrieben. Das stimmt wie so ein, was ist das, was, nee, wie heißt das immer? Wer ist das Spiel?
Ja, wer bin ich?
Ja, wer bist, wer sind wir?
Wo sind wir? Ich weiss es nicht.
Und er hat tatsächlich, und da habe ich mir heute gedacht, wie konnten wir uns das auch nur im Ansatz gefallen lassen, er hat den Satz geschrieben, solange ich nicht weiss, welcher Mitarbeiter den Fehler begangen hat, bekommt niemand Gehalt. Ja, das ist nicht, der funktioniert so nicht. Nee, überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht. Aber wir waren alle Studenten, das war das einzige, was er... Er hat uns in einer Karikatur gelebt, als hättest du in einem Ralf-Rude-Comic gelebt. Ja, aber es war wirklich, der war total gestört. Du kannst aber auch niemandem was sie entziehen, da hast du alle Regeln des Universums gebrochen. Ja, ich weiß, aber du, wenn du ein 18-jähriger Student bist, dann kannst du ja nicht, dann kannst du ja nicht eine Revolution anzetteln, dann kannst du ja sagen, ich kündige, aber dann am Ende, und das war wirklich Stress, also das war wirklich Terror, weil der hat dann wirklich die Leute erpresst und versucht. Wer war's denn? Ja, ich war's. Ja war es. Was war denn der Fehler, der begangen wurde? Es war tatsächlich ich und ich habe mich dann auch gestellt. Nein, was war denn der Fehler? Das gibt es dich jetzt nicht. Doch, doch. Also ich habe ihn dann scharf kritisiert für seine Hexenjagdmethoden und habe gesagt, dass solche Fehler entstehen, weil die an den Mitarbeiter so unter Druck stehen, weil du zu jedem Fehler sowas machst. Und der Fehler war, dass mich hat jemand angerufen. Das war der Callcenter-Job, ne? Ja, das war ein anderer. Und dann hat mich jemand angerufen und dann sollte ich die mit dem Chef verbinden. Und dann habe ich den Chef angerufen und habe mit dem geredet und habe aber nicht erwähnt, dass jemand noch in der Leitung ist. Und dann habe ich ihm gesagt, da ist jemand in der Leitung, soll ich den durchstellen? Und dann habe ich ihn durchgestellt und dann hatte die Person schon aufgelegt, weil ich so lange gewartet habe sozusagen. Und diese Person konnte nie wieder gefunden werden. Und es war vielleicht irgendein wichtiger Geschäftspartner und alles. Und da hat seine Mitarbeiter immer extrem penibel vorgegeben, was sie zu tun haben. Also es gab für jede Aktion, die ein Mitarbeiter tun konnte, immer so ein Protokoll. Mach erst das, mach erst das, mach erst das. Und dann habe ich argumentiert, mit seinen eigenen Regeln habe ich gesagt, der einzige Grund, warum wir sie anrufen, ist, um jemanden durchzustellen. Weil er hat dann gesagt, warum hast du nicht gesagt, dass du jemanden in der Leitung hast? Und dann habe ich geschrieben, ich hätte dich gar nicht angerufen, wenn ich niemanden in der Leitung gehabt hätte. Hier, dich, pardon, sie gar nicht in der Leitung. Angerufen. Das war dann mein Argument, nicht das beste Argument der Welt, ist auch immer schön, im Nachhinein, Jahre später, dann seine eigene Argumentation zu lehnen und zu sagen, du hast faktisch recht, aber du weißt doch schon, was er meint. Oder sag das nächste Mal doch einfach, hallo, ich habe jemanden in der Leitung, so, kannst du einfach sagen, so, aber nein, ich habe darauf gepocht. Und das war die Hexenjagd und ich habe mich dann gestellt und ja, das war bei mir waren Bewerbungen die ersten Mails, die ich jetzt gesehen habe. Wie geht das denn? Wie kann man als erstes Werbung bekommen? Bewerbungen? Ach, Bewerbung. Ich habe mich bei Leuten hier in Köln, war ich kurz davor nach Köln zu ziehen, habe mich hier bei Leuten beworben und habe wirklich, wie ich das immer mache, an alle geschrieben einfach, alle. Und dann kamen sehr viele Absagen zurück, also eigentlich von allen, WDR, Brainpool damals, also mein Leben hätte in sämtliche Richtungen auch verlaufen können, je nachdem, wo ich genommen worden wäre. Und dann haben die alle abgesagt und manche haben zugesagt und manche von denen, die cool waren, die ich cool fand, haben zugesagt. Und dann habe ich aber auf keine geantwortet, außer die, die ich cool fand. Und eigentlich war es zu 80 Prozent waren die ersten Mails, die mich dafür verurteilen, dass ich denen nicht antworte. Und manche habe ich dann aber zurückgeschrieben, dann haben manche coolen dann doch wieder abgesagt, weil dann war der Platz schon weg oder keine Ahnung oder die haben noch jemand anderes gefunden und sowas und dann bin ich dann wieder angekrochen gekommen bei denen, die auch schon zugesagt haben, aber halt viel zu spät und dann haben die geschrieben, ehrlich jetzt, Herr Tietze, nach acht Wochen schreiben Sie mir zurück, dass Sie das Praktikum noch wollen und sowas. Eigentlich waren das wirklich sehr viele Mails in diesem Ton,, viel zu spät, natürlich ist es mittlerweile schon vergeben.
Aber ist gut, das nachzuvollziehen. Hast du das dann mittlerweile verbessert, dass du antwortest, oder kommt es immer noch ab und zu vor, dass du nicht antwortest?
Ja, da waren jedenfalls sehr viele Mails dabei, die sehr weird waren, auch in so einem komischen Ton. Eine war, sie sollten sich vielleicht mal entscheiden, was sie wollen. Was in dem Kontext total stimmt, aber ich habe einfach dem nicht zurückgeschrieben. Und er wird dann so pseudophilosophisch, weil ich nicht genau verstanden habe, was nimmt er sich denn raus, nach einer nicht gekommenen Antwort direkt zu schreiben, ich glaube, sie sollten sich mal entscheiden, was sie wollen. So als wüsste er, dass ich ganz viele andere Mails bekomme und es völlig recht hat. Aber konnte er nicht wissen. Aber ich finde es schon wichtig. Also ich bin ein großer Freund der Absage. Absagen ist immer unangenehm, aber es ist wirklich gut. Sagt ab. Wenn ihr irgendwas nicht machen wollt, einfach absagen. Du bist kein Fan vom Schäbelzustand. Nee, wenn ihr zu einer Party eingeladen werdet und ihr wollt nicht kommen, sagt, nee, ich komme nicht. Einfach sofort absagen. Es ist viel besser, es ist unangenehm, aber es ist viel besser, als dann einfach nicht zu erscheinen. Immer absagen, tut, macht jetzt, lasst uns heute mal den heutigen Tag, den 9. Juni zum Absagetag machen, 9. Juni, einfach absagen. Alles, heute einfach alle Anfragen, die ihr offen stehen habt, heute einfach mal nehmt einen Stift und Zettel in die Hand, macht euch irgendwie schön ein Stacey-Orico-Album aufs Ohr und dann einfach mal abarbeiten, absagen. Alles absagen, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nee, nein, mein ich, mein ich, kommt nicht in die Tüte, nein, auf gar keinen Fall, nein, stopp, hör auf, nein, einfach mal alle wegballern.
Auch Sachen, die wir nicht wollen.
Nein, weg, nein, hör auf, ich antworte nicht.
Apropos, mich haben beunruhigende Nachrichten erreicht bezüglich dir, du bezüglich, bezüglich dir, bezüglich du und zwar dein Verhalten wurde angeprangert. Ja, von wem. Und anscheinend hast du vor einigen Folgen, als es um das Thema Allergie ging, hast du ein gewisses Medikament empfohlen. Mir hat jemand geschrieben in einem recht panischen Ton, bitte weiss Stefan darauf hin, dass dieses Medikament abhängig machen kann. Ich hatte eine Abhängigkeit hinter mir. Stefan, bist du Allergie-Medikament abhängig? Ich bin Reaktindu abhängig. Das ist eine Intervention. Aber hallo, oh nein. Kommt rein, kommt rein. Was machst du denn jetzt hier? Was ist das für Käppis? Was ist das für Cappies? Die haben wir anfertigen lassen. Wir sind hier, weil du uns wichtig hast. Die tragen dir alle schon auf dem Weg hierher? Habt ihr die erst hier aufgesetzt oder habt ihr den ganzen Weg schon diese Cappie getragen? Auf dem Weg im U-Bahn? Direkt vor der Haltestelle? Oh mein Gott. Seit der U-Bahn tragen wir diese Caps, auf der draufsteht Stefan, wir lieben dich, aber du konsumierst einfach zu viel Reaktienduo.
Ähm, also.
Jetzt, wir sind hier, wir wollen dich nicht konfrontieren.
Ja, naja, ich bin noch kurz in diesem, soll ich Lügen-Modus oder nicht?
Soll ich noch abstreiten, dass ich mit ...
Ah, das ist erst Denial, ne, glaube ich, das ist die erste Phase.
Denial, ich bin aber schon in Verhandlungen. Ja, stimmt, Verhandlungen. Ich glaube, Verhandlungen ist das dritte. Naja, ich glaube das vierte. Ich bin auf jeden Fall schon darin. Nee, du bist immerhin auch in Verhandlungen und verhandelst, in welcher Reihenfolge die Phase kommt. Ja, na ja, weiß ich, also ja, na ja, weil, nee, weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls. Ich bin nicht in Wut, ich bin in Verhandlung! Ich bin in Verhandlung. Ich bin medikamentenabhängig, ich war lange Nasenspray-abhängig, was in etwa die uncoolste Abhängigkeit der Welt ist. In so einem Stuhlkreis mit so Heroin-Meth-Abhängigen und du so, ja, ich mag Nasenspray. Ich liebe Nasenspray. Und alle ...
Nee, ist ein ernstes Thema.
Ist ein ernstes Thema. Und wir haben uns da recherchiert.
Warum lachst du dann so?
Wir haben recherchiert, und das ist ein ernstes Thema.
Und wir wollen dir helfen, weil du uns wichtig bist.
Wir würden dich nicht gerne gehen sehen in diese Sucht.
Und wir haben auch bemerkt, dass sie dich verändert als Mensch.
Ja, also was kurz zu reaktiven Duo zu sagen ist, ich kann nichts dafür, dass die neben dem Allergiewirkstoff quasi Crystal Meth da reinmachen. Was ist das denn auch für eine Idee? Das ist so, als ob du jetzt einfach angenommen hast Halsschmerzen und dann hast du dieses Halsschmerzmittel drin und danach und daneben einfach Kokain. Die haben Pseudoephedrin, haben sich entschieden, Pseudoephedrin zu nehmen, um die einmüdende Wirkung von Cedricin aufzuhebeln. Das ist doch bescheuert, diese Idee. Natürlich ist es fantastisch, das zu nehmen. Es macht richtig viel Spaß, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ich freue mich jedes Jahr auf die Allergiesaison. Jetzt habe ich wieder zwei Packungen gekauft, gestern erst, in der Apotheke. Und dann haben die gesagt, das soll man nicht immer nehmen. Und auch nur, eigentlich nur eine Packung kaufen, wo sechs drin sind, sechs Tabletten.
Ja.
Ich habe gestern zwei gekauft und das machen die schon nicht so gern. Dann kriegt man schon diesen Apothekerblick, diesen, ja gut, aber der hält man schon seine Arme. Ich hau nicht auf.
Nee, ich setze diesen traurigen Blick auf, diesen schniefigen Blick und dann sagen die, ja okay, aber das soll man nur kurz nehmen, nicht über den ganzen Zeitraum, über die ganze Saison, das darf man natürlich nicht. Mir geht es gut, ich bin auf dem Weg der Besserung. Ich nehme jetzt nur noch eine, so alle zwei Tage neben meiner Tablette. Und wann endet dieser Zeitraum, dieser Allergiezeitraum? Ja, wenn ich jetzt nicht drüber nachdenke.
Aber du hast einen Termin gesetzt, ab dem du...
Ja!
Wann ist der Termin denn?
Was ist denn das Datum, ab dem du das nicht mehr nimmst?
September.
September?
2022.
Stefan.
Was?
Wir haben diese Schals und diese T-Shirts extra bedrucken lassen, es war verdammt teuer. Das ist ja viel zu warm für Schals. Es ist ein bisschen schwitzig, ihr könnt die ruhig abnehmen, ihr könnt die ruhig abnehmen. Du bist uns wichtig, Stefan. Okay, ja dann, ich habe auch jetzt gehört, es gibt andere Allergietabletten, die ähnlich geil sind, aber ohne Pseudorphirin zumindest. Heroin heißen die. Wenn ich zumindest vom Pseudo runterkomme, würde mir ja schon helfen. Wir haben jetzt dieses Heroin im Angebot, den wir mal probieren, wenn ihr möchtet. Heroin. Mit einem Löffel. Ich habe tatsächlich extrem wenig Erfahrung mit Medikamenten. Medikamenten spielen in meinem Leben überhaupt keine Rolle. Bei mir eigentlich auch nicht. Wenn Leute sagen so, willst du eine Kopfschmerztablette? Ich sage, nee, ich nehme nie irgendwas. Es gibt auch Leute, die, also es gibt diese Leute, die finde ich noch angenehm.
Und ich habe auch ASS und ich habe auch, das wird mir immer zu viel.
Hallo, wir sind keine Apotheker, wir haben nicht drei verschiedene Kopfschmerztabletten mitzuführen.
Willst du eine Ibu?
Die Abkürzungen für diese lateinischen Wörter benutzen, das ist mir schon ein Suspekt.
Leute, die Ibu sagen, wissen es schon, auch die Angina sagen, Influenza, statt ein bisschen fiebrig. Bisschen schwummerig am Abend. Bisschen trümmlig. Ne, stimmt schon, aber ich wünsche auf jeden Fall gute Besserung, aber finde ich auch toll von unserer Community, dass sie auch aufpasst, dass wir nicht abrutschen. Also falls euch irgendwas von uns, unserem Verhalten auffällt, egal ob es inhaltlich sei oder irgend sonstiges, gerne Nachrichten. Wir haben da eine Notfallhotline, falls ihr etwas bemerkt, Verhalten, das euch auffällt. Und wir nehmen das gerne an, wir sind da dem Feedback immer zugeneigt. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Leute, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, eher mal Diagnosen bekommen wie Demenz oder sowas, weil wir natürlich immer unter Beobachtung stehen. Ja, es gibt doch einige Fälle von Streamern oder so, wo es dann hieß, hey, du hast irgendwie einen Leberfleck auf der Stirn, der wird größer, geh mal zum Arzt, stellst dich raus, ja, ist tatsächlich irgendwas Gefährliches und wird rausgenommen. Deine Augen sind zu gelb, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Leberschaden, Nierenschaden. Das ist ja mega gut einfach so, wenn Leute darauf hinweisen. Oder ja, da gibt es tatsächlich diesen einen, bei Reddit gibt es auch so ein, so was ist falsch mit mir, Subreddit, wo Leute immer posten können. Da gibt es einen ganz legendären Post schon vor langer Zeit. Mit den Post-its. Mit den Post-its, ja, kennst du den? Ich finde den so grossartig. Hatte ich jetzt auch so einen ähnlichen Incident, über den ich nicht reden darf, weil es die Illegalität tangiert. Stichwort Gas bei mir zu Hause. Ja, genau. Und der hatte das Ähnliche, der hatte nämlich ein grosses Gas-Lack bei sich zu Hause, wusste aber nicht von. Er hat einfach nur überall Post-its gefunden in seiner Handschrift, auf denen er sich sagt, was er machen soll und Erinnerungen. Genau, er hat auf Reddit gepostet, hey, ich finde immer diese Post-it-Notes. Bricht jemand in meine Wohnung ein, was ist los, ich kann es mir nicht erklären, stellt sich raus, hat ein Lack von Kohlenmonoxid und konnte sich nicht daran erinnern, dass er es gemacht hat. Genau, ein User hat dann geschrieben, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Kohlenmonoxid-Lag bei dir. Lass das mal checken, wahrscheinlich ist die Konzentration zu hoch und dein Gehirn hat kein Kurzzeitgedächtnis mehr. Ja. Ja, war so. Es kommt tatsächlich recht häufig vor. Wir haben da mal bei Rocket Beans drüber gesprochen und da haben tatsächlich Leute angerufen, die gesagt haben, ja, ich hatte das auch mal irgendwie, dass ich immer mega müde war und ich wusste nicht, was los ist und so. Und oft ist das einfach Kohlenmonoxid irgendwie. Also falls es euch schlecht geht, unerklärbar, testet einfach mal, vielleicht habt ihr irgendwie so eine Gasleck. Was habe ich deswegen bei Film ein? So, wow. Und jetzt kommt die Klammer. Und jetzt wird es spannend. Ja, Moment, aber hast du ein Gasleck oder was? Nee. Blinzelt dreimal, wenn du ein Gasleck hast in deiner Wohnung. Hatte. Vielleicht. Aber was ist denn Kohlenmonoxid? Warum braucht man das denn? Wo kommt das denn her? Das weiß ich auch nicht. Das ist einfach Abgase. Das ist so vom Herd, oder was? Das sind Abgase. Ist der Garage, oder wo kommt das her? Naja, wenn du eine Tiefgarage hast, keine Ahnung, wo soll das denn herkommen? Na, Kohlenmonoxid, bin ich mir auch nicht sicher, wo das herkommt. Weil wenn man ausatmet, ist es ja Kohlendioxid, oder? Das ist ja CO2. Ja. So, das gibt es ja viele. Kohlenmonoxid ist auf Stickstoff oder nicht? Ja, was weiß ich. Wahrscheinlich nicht, weil das ist nur Stickstoff zu sagen. Da braucht ihr uns jetzt auch nicht schreiben, sowas können wir googlen, da brauchen wir euch nicht so. Wir müssen es googlen, weil wenn wir es spannend genug finden, dann zu googlen. Nee, ich hatte Propangasleck. Ja, von deinem Grill? Ja. Ich mag es, wenn sich solche Story-Args schliessen für vier Wochen. Das war so leicht, den Grill aufzubauen und es hat zu Spaß gemacht. Ich habe überlegt, soll ich deinen Experten anrufen? Nee, ich habe den selber zusammengebaut und mir ein Steak gemacht. Vier Wochen später, ja, ich hatte ein massives Gasleck. Ich schlaf immer bei Filmen ein. Ja, na ja. Nee, ist ein bisschen anders, kann ich nicht sagen. Sonst kommt mir ein Knast. Und das ist auch nur eine Frage der Zeit. Aber dann habe ich mich gefragt, kann man nicht vor Gericht einfach sagen, wir machen Comedy? Wie, du hast jemanden aus Spaß umgebracht oder was? Nee, kann man nicht vor Gericht, also angenommen, wir werden irgendwann belangf... Wenn wenn ich jetzt sage, wenn ich jetzt aus Spaß sagen würde, ich habe einen Gasherd bei mir in der Wohnung, den man so nicht betreiben dürfte, theoretisch, angenommen, ich sage das im Spaß hier und dann vor Gericht, wäre ich dann vor Gericht gezogen und das wird als Beweis herangeführt, kann ich dann nicht mit meinem Anwalt, Salis Gutmann,
kann der dann nicht sagen,
nee, aber mein Klient macht ja einen Comedy-Podcast.
Ja, dann erzählen Sie mal einen Witz,
wenn Sie so lustig sind, Herr Tietze.
Dann seien Sie mal lustig, beweisen Sie der Jury mal,
dass Sie ein lustiger Typ sind.
Ja, davon habe ich so Angst. Ich kenne keinen Witz.
Dann stehst du auf, nimmst das Mikrofon.
Entschuldigung, mir fällt gerade kein Witz ein. Kennt ihr U-Bahn? Immer diese Durchsagestimme, so nächster Halt? Ich meine, ja natürlich. Aufstieg in Fahrtrichtung rechts. Warum ist es manchmal rechts, manchmal links? Das ist so ein bisschen wie die deutsche Geschichte. Also, okay, politisch. Ja, schuldig. Schuldig, hold den Streck. Nee, genau, aber weißt du, was ich meine? Weil alles, was wir im Podcast du hast mal gesagt, dass du Dinge aus dem Fenster wirfst, auf Passanten. Was? Pass auch zum Thema der Folge, aber daran kann ich mich nicht erinnern, das gesagt zu haben. Habe ich das im Schlaf gesagt? Bin ich eingeschlafen? Das ist immer Essen aus dem Fenster geworfen hast. Essen? Was für Essen? Weiß ich nicht mehr. Aber mir fällt nichts ein, was du wirklich gemacht hast. Ich glaube, ich habe Urin aus dem Fenster geworfen. Nee, ja, das hast du auch mal jetzt. Das habe ich auch mal gemacht. Aber das ist ja per se nicht verboten, oder? Nee, genau. Mir ist gerade nur nichts Besseres eingefallen, was verboten ist. Weil, angenommen, kann man jemanden aus dem Comedy-Podcast heraus mit Informationen, die ein Comedy-Podcast teilt, verurteilen? Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Naja, also wir haben, also ich würde jetzt erstmal vorsichtig sein, weil wir haben mindestens eine Polizistin, die unseren Podcast hört, von der wir wissen. Das heißt, es kann gut sein, dass die dich sofort verhaftet, wenn du sagst, ich bin bei Rot über die Ampel gelaufen. Aber gibt es nicht auch so ein, man kann sich nicht selber belasten, Ding oder so? Ich glaube, man muss sichasten. Ja genau, man kann sich dummerweise sehr gut selber belasten. Aber der Richter muss nachfragen. Sind Sie sich sicher, dass Sie das sagen wollen, Hettice? Nein. Nein, streichen Sie das aus dem Protokoll. Und die Protokoll ist so, oh man. Oh, das war so schön. Man, der hat gestanden. Scheiße, radiert alles. Radiert nicht? Rütend weg. Schauen die mit Bleistift? Nee, die haben Ratzefummel dabei. Ratzefummel. Haben sie schön dabei, hinten am Stift dran. Ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Wofür ist die blaue Seite beim Radiergummi? Das ist die Legende, man weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Eine Legende wäre ja, wenn es eine Legende gäbe. Ich glaube, die Legende ist, dass man damit hinterweg radieren kann, aber ich glaube, es stimmt nicht. Kann man nicht. Aber ich weiß es nicht, bei mir, Radiergummi hatte ich nie. Ich habe dann immer nur so bei so Aktionstagen, wo dann so eine Firma da war, die uns rekrutieren wollte, Kaugummis aus, äh, die Bundeswehr. Radiergummi, Bundeswehr, so ein Panzer. Firma, wieso Firma? Panzerradiergummi. Weil wir bei der BRD GmbH sind oder was. Kamen waren eure Schule nicht manchmal Firmen, die euch wegrekrutieren wollten? Null, null Firmen. Ja gut, die war auf so einer Eliteschule, da ist es natürlich klar, dass da die ganzen, da kommt Blackrock vorbei und sagt, hey, mögt ihr Geld?
Bei uns kam Google, um zu sagen,
du brauchst dich einfach, du brauchst dich gar nicht jetzt bewerben.
Wir haben eure Google-Suchen geprüft
und aus euch wird nichts.
Wasser, Wasser,
nass, warum, schnell,
vergess es, streich ihn von deinem.
Gas, lag, wo?
Warum schlaffe ich immer Eier? Warum schlafe ich immer Eier? Wo kommt dieses Zzzzzzz um Schlaf zu tun? Ja, das ist dieses Das ist der zweite Teil, du hast ja diesen Schnarch und dann Also ich müsste zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zäh, zähfen wir mal neben einer Person, die einfach so zzzzzz. Daher. Man macht da wieder auf und malt sein Comic weiter. Oder so die Frau von Disney. Die Frau von Disney hat vielleicht so ein bisschen im Schlaf, aber ein bisschen gerated. Gerated. Gerated. Ich glaube, man kann sich selber belasten. Also auch im Podcast. Ich glaube, es gibt schon so eine Spaßklausel, dass man Spaß danach sagt, dass es dann nicht gilt. Aber es gibt ja ganz verrückte Gesetze. Du kannst ja zum Beispiel auch, es gibt so eine Ausnahme, dass Schauspieler, Theaterschauspieler zum Beispiel, so eine Stunde nach ihrem Auftritt so eine Art Sonderstellung haben, dass wenn die dann jemanden umbringen und gerade Mephisto gespielt haben, Hitler heißt es so, ja gut, aber der war noch in der Rolle, der war noch so tief in der Rolle, der war nicht sehr selbst. Das heißt, die Idee müsste sein, so eine Freifahrtschein Rolle zu spielen. Also so Rollen, wo man danach sagt, ja, also jemand, der so alles machen kann. Ja, Hitler, so Iphigenie. Iphigenie. Aber ist es ja nicht so, dass nachdem ein Mörder gespielt wird, wird man so eine Stunde lang im Theater gehalten, damit man runterkommt oder so? Ja, vielleicht. Wenn man irgendwie so Herkules gespielt hat oder so, ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung, ob es jemals tatsächlich in Effekte getreten ist. In Deutschland darf man auch nicht als Schauspieler mehr Auto fahren, während man dreht. Ja? Ja, weil dass du nicht die Kontrolle
über deinen kompletten Körper hast.
Schauspieler werden auch so albern,
sorry, aber ihr Schauspieler,
das ist so albern, wie die,
wie alles, die immer eine Sonderstellung haben,
in allen Bereichen.
Auch sowas wie,
nicht Auto fahren zu dürfen, während man seinen Job ausübt,
ist ja in den meisten Fällen komplett egal, aber bei Schauspielern ist immer so eine, oh, in diesem geistigen Zustand.
Ich kann das verstehen, mich macht das total nervös in Filmen, wenn Leute in Autos sind und lange Zeit nicht auf die Strasse gucken.
Oh mein Gott.
Das macht mich so wirklich...
Aber das drehen die ja meistens nicht auf echten Strasse, sondern einfach...
Nee, nee, klar, die Schauspieler sind in keiner Gefahr, das ist mir schon klar, aber trotzdem ist es so, wirklich so, wenn du nicht alle drei Sekunden auf die Strasse guckst
und dann reden die so einen total emotionalen Dialog und so, ich hab die Filme so nicht, ja, schau auf die Strasse, verdammt! Du weißt nicht, was da ist! Ich denke mir auch immer, in Drehbuchautoren sitzen da bestimmt ein Jahr an dieser Szene und alles, was ich denke, ist, guck auf die Strasse, guck auf die Strasse, Große Strasse, Große Strasse, bitte bitte bitte bitte, Große Strasse.
Strasse!
Ja, und ganz wichtige Film-Unfektionen fallen durch und ich schlafe eh kurz ein.
Du schläfst kurz ein, wachst auf, rufst Straße, stellst wieder ein, kommen und gehen, Popcorn fällt runter. Aber du kommst aus dem Kino und sagst, ja, war gut, war gut, ja. Ja, wir hatten ja tatsächlich, wir hatten ja auch mal eine Autoszene bei Gute Arbeit Originals für diesen Trailer. Wir hatten tatsächlich einen Unfall gebaut und dann sind wir halt ... Also einen Unfall gebaut. Ja, gibt es auch in den Outtakes, Gute Arbeit Outtakes. Und da sind wir so hinter dem Auto hergefahren, das mit so einer Abschleppstange, eine Stange, gezogen wurde. Aber ein normales Auto, also nicht so ein Sonderauto, sondern einfach ein normales Auto hinten abgeschleppt. Und Katjana saß am Steuer. Und dann sind wir durch so einen Kreisverkehr gefahren und dadurch, dass sie so gelenkt hat in den Kreisverkehr, ist irgendwie das Lenkrad eingerastet, so ganz weit links. Also eine Funktion, die heute nicht mehr in Autos gebaut wird. Doch, die Lenkradsperre. Dass wenn man ganz nach links lenkt, die einhakt. Doch, die Lenkradsperre. Aber das ist das Dümmste, was du in dein Auto bauen kannst. Lenkradsperre, du fährst ja auch kein fucking Auto, wenn es aus ist. Naja, Berg runter, Seifenkisten, war so ein Unfall. Ja, auf jeden Fall ist es dann eingerastet und Katjana konnte nicht mehr nach rechts lenken und ist dann sozusagen in diese Stange gefahren. Es ist nichts passiert, aber es war das Nächste, was ich hier in einem Autounfall war. Und man merkt... Ihr hattet doch beide einen Schock im Gesicht. Ja, wir hatten beide so Jesus. War echt toll, hat echt Spaß gemacht.
Und ich weiß jetzt auch, was meine letzten Worte sind, wenn ich sterbe.
Und weil wir wirklich in der Situation waren, man denkt sich ja immer so, man würde irgendwie schreien. Irgendwas cooles, du sagst Jesus und du sagst Holy Fuck.
Sag meiner Frau, dass ich sie liebe und nee, du sagst What the Fuck.
Ja, im schlechtem Englisch sagst du What the Fuck.
What the hell? Ja, im Schlechtem Englisch sagst du, what the fuck? What the hell? What the... What the damn? Hast du das manchmal? Why? Dass du alleine im Auto bist und schimpfst? Ja, natürlich. Und dich versprichst? Und dich selber korrigierst? Und manchmal auch nicht. Jetzt habe ich neulich zum ersten Mal gedacht, ich habe mich dann korrigiert, als ich dann zum ersten Mal zu mir selber la geschimpft habe im Auto, habe mich dann korrigiert und dachte mir danach, du musst dich nicht korrigieren.
Es ist niemand da, vor dem du nicht korrigieren musst. Ich wusste ja, was ich sagen wollte. Ich bin ja der einzige Insasse gerade. Und du weißt ja, dass du falsch lagst. Also musst du dich nicht korrigieren.
Ich habe mit mir selber keinen selten Streit. Alle Beteiligten im Auto wussten, es, es wurde, jeder weiß, was gesagt wurde, jeder weiß, wo der Fehler war, easy. Korrigiert man sich alleine. Oder manchmal spricht man so, man verspricht sich dann so beim Aufregen, das macht mich noch wütender immer, wenn man sich so aufregt mit dem Autofahrer und man sagt what the fuck und verschluckt dann das T8 und denkt sich, oh du Depp, das war noch saurer. Dir keinen kein Schimpf oder einfach, what the fuck, du Schniesel, Schiesling, ach, scheiß, vergiss es. Deswegen, wir haben ja schon gesagt, wir können nicht streiten, einfach weil wir nicht züberein genug sind, aber ich denke ja auch, es gibt ja manchmal so in Filmen so Szenen, dass jemand sich so auf der Rückbank versteckt oder im Kofferraum oder so und dann mitten in der Fahrt den töten will oder so, aber in den Filmen hört man relativ selten, was die Person dann die ganze Zeit so anfängt zu singen und zu schimpfen und der Mörder hinten auf der Rückbank einfach so. Ich nehme auch, ich würde sofort auffliegen, weil der Mörder würde sofort fliehen, weil das ist ein absolut Psychopath im Auto. Ja, im Auto. Ja, bei einer Heimatstadt Ebersberg gibt es die Legende der weißen Frau, so wenn man durch den Forst fährt und dann steht dann so eine weisse Frau an der, also in weisser Kleidung am Strassenrand und wenn man die, die möchte mitgenommen werden und wenn man die nicht mitnimmt, dann erscheint sie hinten auf dem Rücksitz und erschreckt den Fahrer so sehr, dass er einen Unfall baut. So, und auch da dachte ich mir immer so, so in diesem Moment man singt so, ja, na na na na, da singt, na na na, und dann plötzlich ist diese Frau so, what the fuck, und dann baut man keinen Unfall. Und dann fährt man halt weiter. Und dann fährt man die dann wohin? Wohin will die denn genommen werden? Das ist das Problem an der Legende, niemand weiß, was passiert, wenn man sie mitnimmt. Sagt sie dann, du, sorry, passt schon, ich steig direkt vorne wieder aus und lauf zurück, weil ich wollte eigentlich nur Leute nehmen. Das ist ein Test, das ist ein Test, ich bin Test. Passt schon, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass jemand kommt, bist du ja erst so heute, aber geil, danke dir, danke dir. Ne, ist es, hä? Und haben da mal sich Mädels den Spaß erlaubt und sich als weiße Frau an den Strassen hergestellt? Das weiß ich nicht, kann gut sein, ich glaube, es gibt ja so irgendwie anscheinend so eine Stelle in dem Wald, wo häufiger Unfälle sind und dann hat sich so diese, weil das ist nach so einer Kapelle und dann hat sich die Legende irgendwie entwickelt. Ich glaube, da gibt es sogar eine Serie zu Ebersberg, glaube ich, heißt die, aber habe ich nicht gesehen, weil ich dachte, ich kenne das ja schon. Ein ganz dummer Gedanke. Ja, so geht es ja bei vielen Serien auch. Wenn ich aber ein Buch drüber gelesen habe, nee, kenne ich ja schon.
Deswegen auch so, wenn du so im Krieg warst und dann so Kriegsfilm, ja, kenne ich ja schon.
Kenne ich ja schon.
Hab ich ja nicht.
Hab ich schon miterlebt.
Argo, war ich dabei, war einer von diesen Botschaftern. Manchmal würde ich mir wünschen, mein Opa war ja in Kriegsgefangenschaft, schön in Russland gewesen. Dem habe ich jetzt zum Beispiel gerne mal Dunkirk gezeigt im Kino. Mal gucken, was passiert. Weil ich glaube, dem auch nicht alles, was er gesagt hat. Zum Beispiel. Weiß ich nicht. Und dass er sagen kann, was daran korrekt ist und was nicht geht. Nee, ich hätte ihn einfach mal angeguckt und nicht den Film, um zu gucken, was da so kommt, wie er damit umgeht. Hat jemand von euch einen Opa, der sich einfrieren lassen. Taut den mal auf und zeigt ihm Dunkirk, zum Beispiel. Oder halt ein, oder weiß ich nicht. Ich fand Dunkirk so langweilig, es tut mir echt leid. Oder jetzt, wie hieß der andere Film? 1813, 1817. 1917, ja. Das war nicht viel besser. Aber Quentin Tarantino hat ja gesagt, dass Dunkirk der beste Film der letzten 20 Jahre ist oder so. Das ist ja wirklich Social Network. Aber Dunkirk ist ja auch sehr weit oben in der Liste. Ist der Film, der der beste Film des Jahres 20 Jahres oder so, das ist ja wirklich Social Network, aber Dunkirk ist auch sehr weit oben in der Liste. Der Film war der beste Film des Jahres, meint er, glaube ich. Ja, genau, beste Film des Jahres, stimmt, Social Network, habe ich ja auch gedacht, gut kann ich, finde ich auch. Aber Dunkirk hat mich überhaupt nicht berührt. Doch, fand ich schon cool, aber jetzt auch nicht mein Bläuern cool, aber geile Visuals mal wieder, also ich fand das sehr schön anzugucken. Ja. Jedenfalls weiß ich nicht, wie er halt, ich würde auf diesen Film reagieren. Gut, der ist ein bisschen sehr artifiziell jetzt vielleicht auch. Ja. Aber so, vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, sagt er mal mehr. Ja, weiß ich nicht, bei dieser Eröffnungsszene von Saving Private Ryan, dieser D-Day, Sturm auf die Normandie, da gibt es ja Interviews mit Veteranen, die es erlebt haben, und die meinten, das sei relativ akkurat, also so akkurat, wie ein Film sein kann. Aber die meinten so, da war jetzt kein großer Fehler dabei. Da war jetzt kein Tonangel im Bild. Kein irgendwie, wir hatten kein Catering eigentlich. Kein großer Schlitzrand eigentlich. Aber na ja, gut, auf jeden Fall schwierig. Aber ich glaube, es ist ganz gut, wenn man einen Beruf hat, über den selten Filme gemacht werden, damit man alle Filme genießen kann und nicht immer sagen kann, so läuft das aber nicht in Reaktionsräumen. Machen wir deswegen Filme? Kann sein. Es gibt Filme über Leute, die Filme machen, auch manchmal. Argo habe ich gesehen zum Beispiel. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass der Film so ist, wie er ist. Ich dachte, das wäre so, es ist schon ein spannendes Drama oder so, aber der ist auch witzig. Magst du Argo? Ich mag Argo. Er sagt, dass meine Leute auf meiner Ex-Strasse die Argo hassen. Ja, irgendwie, ich habe den letztens auf der Strasse gefunden und jetzt dachte ich mir, gucke ich den mal an. Und habe mich durchaus, ja, fand ich. Was mir aber erst später aufgefallen ist, es war die einzige DVD dabei, Rest waren Blu-Rays. Ach so. So, jetzt die Frage. Die haben mir ganzes Geld für den Blu-ray-Player ausgegeben. Wäre Argo ein Blu-ray gewesen, wäre Argo vielleicht jetzt in anderen Händen. Kann auch sein. So habe ich Argo noch bei mir zu Hause. Ja. Und an denjenigen, der mir verrät, warum ich bei Filmen immer einschlafe, der kriegt eine Argo-DVD nach Hause geschickt. Ja, stimmt schon. Willst du es mit Serien? Aber machst du dann, setzt du dich dann bewusst hin und guckst es an, oder ist es so nebenbei oder so richtig Sofa-Aktion? Bewusst an, schlafen. Mache ich jetzt nämlich auch, immer bewusst Sofa und Film gucken, weil ich so ein bisschen meine Aufmerksamkeitsspanne wieder eindrehen will, weil ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen zu früh abgebogen. Du hast selbst gerade bei dem Wort aufregend Spanne. Das Interesse verloren. Interesse verloren. Ich habe mich selbst gelangen. An dem Satz. Ich habe innerlich schon den neuen Tab aufgemacht. Aber es ist schlimm geworden, bei mir auch. Aber ja, ich habe echt überlegt, ob ich jetzt einführen soll, dass ich, also das ist ein bisschen albern, aber andererseits vielleicht auch mal notwendig, dass ich sowas wie nur noch einmal am Tag Social Media checke. So dass du sagst, ich habe jeden Tag um 16 Uhr schaue ich, was auf Social Media los ist und danach nicht mehr, weil das Problem ist ja, dass so dieses Konstante, hat jemand was Neues gepostet, hat jemand schon auf meine Nachricht reagiert, bla bla bla, so konstant. So und ich glaube, wenn man das auch rein mental kriegt auf einmal am Tag reicht, vielleicht hat man den Rest des Tages frei von diesem konstanten alles checken müssen, weil man weiß ja, das kann ja warten. Ein Freund von mir hat jetzt einfach ganz, ganz viele Seiten auf seinem Handy und ganz, ganz hinten auf der Seite ist ein Ordner und darin sind die ganzen. Unterordner Unterordner. Ja, wenn das geht, kann das sein, weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall sehr viele, also dass du die maximale Anzahl an Klicks brauchst, um auf Instagram zu kommen. Er die ganz hinten versteckt. Und es hat nicht funktioniert, hat er gesagt. Irgendwann ist das egal, der Aufwand ist dir egal, du kriegst WhatsApp drauf. Oder du gehst über die Apps zurück und so kannst du auch hochwischen und dann hast du es auch links direkt. Clever. Ja, Menschen sind das so clever. Aber da gibt es bestimmt Apps, die so wie so eine Art Tresor funktionieren, wo du einprogrammieren kannst, lass mich folgende Apps nur einmal am Tag öffnen, aber selbst dann löscht man halt diese Tresor-App wieder, um reinzukommen. Das ist so, wie wenn man selbst versucht, Süßigkeiten vor einem selber zu verstecken. Ich weiss ja, wo die sind. Oh, mir ist gerade noch eingefallen, wo ich Süßigkeiten habe. Ach so, guck mal, da hat das doch funktioniert. Oh, das ist das beste Gefühl der Welt! Da hat es ja doch funktioniert. Oh, das sind diese ... Ich bin so auf Product Placement reingefallen. Echt? Ich hasse mich selbst und ich verfluche jeden, der sagt, also Werbung funktioniert bei mir nicht, nur weil ich die Produkte sehe, kaufe ich die ja nicht. Erstens, ihr habt keine Ahnung, ihr habt keine Ahnung. Tut nicht, seid ihr besser als alle anderen und gerade, dass ihr denkt, dass es nicht funktioniert, das ist der Beweis, dass es funktioniert. Und zwar habe ich Knives Out gesehen, toller Film, richtig gut gefallen. Ja, ja, ja, ja, gefallen. Dem würde ich ganz toll. Ein mega guter Film. Ich dachte mir erst so, ach ja, da hat man doch schon alles gesehen. Und das ist ein schweres Genre, weil so Krimi hat man halt echt schon alles gesehen. Ich habe acht Staffeln Detective Codden gesehen. Ich liebe diesen Film. Die Stimmung ist cool, alles cool. Man guckt ihm gerne so, sieht super aus, super lustig. Ja, und dann dieser Chris Evans, so ein bisschen der... Wann ist er diesen Mantel gekauft, diesen schönen, weggen Mantel? Nee, diese Kekse, der hat eine Szene, wo er diese Kaffeekse... Und die ist so versteckt bei dir zu Hause? Diese Kaffeekse, und das ist so, ich glaube, das ist offensichtlich ein Parkleis. Dänische Kekse. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, die heißen. Erzähl, die belgische Kekse? Die heißen so Kabal oder Kemal oder irgendwie sowas, Kartell, Karetto, irgendwie sowas. Sind die gut denn? Ja, die sind halt so ein bisschen wie Spekulatius, aber die gibt es halt das ganze Jahr. Und das ist halt sowas, wenn du im Café kriegst, du manchmal so einen Keks zum Cappuccino dazu. Und das sind oft diese Spekulatius-Kekse. Und die hatte die in der Hand. Und ich habe mir geteilt und dachte mir, die wären geil. Aber dann dachte ich mir, nein, nein, nein, nein, du bist jetzt nicht so dumm und fällst auf diese Power Placement rein. Das machst du nicht. Ich mache das sofort. Du hast es gemerkt, es ist jetzt nicht mehr unbewusst, du hast es in einer Kontrolle, du kannst deine Begierden kontrollieren. Nächster Tag Supermarkt gekauft, im vollen Bewusstsein. Ich wusste genau, wo die waren. Ich wusste, als ich die Packung gesehen habe, wusste ich im Supermarkt exakt, Reihe und wo hoch. Und die hast du zu Hause versteckt wie so Alkoholiker? Die habe ich dann gekauft und ich habe sie wirklich gekauft mit dem Wissen, ich mache das nur wegen Product Placement. Ich hatte, davor habe ich die nie gekauft, ab und zu, aber ich habe sie nur gekauft in Broadplace.
Und ich habe mich einerseits schlecht gefühlt, aber andererseits sagte mir, ja mein Gott, die haben da bestimmt Millionen Euro ausgegeben.
Mein Gott, dann kaufe ich halt eine Packung, so ist das okay.
Und dann habe ich die aber versteckt und jetzt ist mir gerade eingefallen, wo ich die verstecke und ich gehe nach Hause und ich werde die wegknabbern schön.
Wo hast du die versteckt?
Ganz oben im Regal, schön ganz oben im Regal und dann so weit hinten geschoben, dass man es von unten nicht sehen kann. Das ist clever. Ich finde auch manchmal eine Chipstüte ganz oben auf dem Regal. Echt? Die da irgendwer versteckt, ich weiß nicht wer. Und Post-Sitz. Also das mit diesem Kohlenmonoxid-Leg wird immer wahrscheinlich, ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde immer so Snacks überall bei mir.
Ich finde überall Snacks.
Ich finde Gold, habe ich gefunden.
Und Nachrichten.
So komische Nachrichten.
Stefan, du hast ein Gas-Leck und sowas.
Mit einem kleinen versteckten Goldstück möchten wir euch auch entlassen für diese Folge,
denn ihr habt ja das Intro gesehen von Daniel Drei, der unsere Top-neuen Hits,
Kein Fun für die Liebe und unnütze Tränen.
Kein Fun für die Liebe, kein Bong für Love. Kein Bong, kein, kein, kein Bong of Love. Kein Bong of Love. Tolle, tolle Zeile, Daniel 3, ganz, ganz grossartig. Jetzt reicht's aber auch wieder. Und es hat noch jemand anders, Hans nämlich, hat noch die Lieder geremixt aus dem, was wir gesagt haben. Und damit entlassen wir euch für diese Woche ganz, ganz viel Spaß. Vielen, vielen Dank an Hans für die Einsendung. Macht's gut. Und an Daniel 3, haut rein, habt eine ganz, ganz schöne Woche.
Checkt eure Gasleitung, macht's gut, ciao, ciao. Macht's gut, haut rein, ciao, wir heben ab, macht's gut, bis dann.
Ja, ja.
Sehnlose Tränen, ich hab für dich geweint, literweise, doch später stellt sich raus, ich krieg kein Pfand zurück, kein Pfand für die Liebe, oder sind sinnlose Tränen, Podcast UFO, wir schreiben unser eigenes Intro.
Sind nicht alle Tränen nützlich?
Hä?
Zu Wort bei Applauschen.